welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series i am of course your
host greg knuckles joined by
my my regular uh co-host eric trexler um
we're we're excited to be back for this
fireside chat which we're putting out
for a handful of reasons uh first people
have been asking for one for a while if
you've recently subscribed to the
stronger by science podcast you may have
never encountered a fireside chat
episode um we started doing them at at
the start of lockdown just so
you know there would be consistent
content in the feed with with friendly
voices talking about fun light-hearted
topics i haven't done one in a while
long time subscribers have been
clamoring for one so that's reason one
uh two we've been away for like five six
weeks so you know thought it would be
good to put out an episode just to just
to catch back up
after the break
and then three and perhaps most
importantly we are trying out a new tech
setup we've got a three camera system
going there have been a lot of kind of
under the hood changes for
the setup for this podcast uh and
there's a decent chance that something
is going to screw up so if you
watch the podcast on youtube this might
be
a more visually interesting episode than
ones you've seen previously or it might
be an audio only episode both are
completely within the realm of
possibility
and so
basically we wanted to put out at least
one fireside chat and if this goes
poorly maybe some more fireside chats
until we can figure out the tech just to
make sure we don't put a ton of work and
effort and research into
a more heavily content-based episode
which then has to be scrapped because
there were recording issues um
so yeah we figured just for trying out
the new tech setup a fireside chat made
the most sense as always if you enjoy
listening to the show
and you want to support it in some way
shape or form
like rate subscribe on whatever
podcast platform you listen to the show
on
like and subscribe on youtube
you can keep up to date with the
research we talk about by subscribing to
our newsletter or check out stronger by
science coaching links to do
both of those things will be in the show
notes
if you use supplements and you want to
get them for
cheap just in general and then even
cheaper yet check out
bulksupplements.com and you can get an
extra five percent off with the code sbs
pod at checkout
uh
if you'd also like to support the show
while keeping up to date on the research
related to strength and hypertrophy body
composition all of the stuff that
strengthen physique athletes care about
you can subscribe to the mass research
review
or if you would
like an app to help you manage your
nutrition manage your diet check out
macro factor uh it has a two week free
trial and uh yeah check that out as well
that is uh
the last thing in my notes kick it over
to eric
yeah so i guess uh first thing we should
do is just kind of recap how our our
summer breaks went um because it has
been about six weeks since we've checked
in with the audience so um
i for one
had a very nice and restful summer break
uh i did my first
work-related travel since like coveted
lockdown started uh which is crazy to
think about like i kind of
didn't realize how long it had been
since i traveled for work
but i presented at the stronger together
fitness conference which was really fun
it was in seattle
and seattle
i had assumed it was gonna be like
really uh
cloudy and overcast and rainy and things
like that but uh seattle in the summer
apparently is just perfect absolutely
beautiful there were like
three clouds total during the weekend
that i was there uh very sunny
perfect temperature like 75 degrees uh
seattle was just a really cool city and
i was staying in the international
district which was awesome uh so like
right across from my hotel there was
like a little japanese garden
and the the like first floor of the
hotel was like a little japanese tea
house um there was a vietnamese buffet
down the street that i went to a couple
times or i went there once and ate a
couple times worth of meals just because
it's a buffet so you have to um but yeah
so so i had a really nice trip over
there uh did a lot of paddle boarding
over the break um
got my car all decked out for a bunch of
camping this fall i've got a plan to uh
basically sleep in the back it's like
it's a toyota rav4
so it's just big enough for someone of
my stature to sleep in the back so i've
got it all like rigged up and ready to
go for some camping trips and
uh
on the show i briefly had a segment
called road to enlightenment i
immediately backpedaled away from it
because i realized that having that
segment would mean i had to produce
content that i was unqualified to
produce i i also imagine eventually it
would get awkward to just talk week to
week about how much more enlightened
you're becoming correct like that that
that is a bizarre flex yeah it was um
it just was it it was not a good idea
and it was never a good idea to be to be
a segment
uh but the road to enlightenment has
been cranked up several notches because
over the break i finally joined a sangha
so in buddhism uh the place where you
study and practice and meditate you know
could be called a meditation center or a
temple or whatever you like but the
sangha is the group of people with which
you study buddhism and practice buddhism
and meditate together and things like
that so uh i tried to join i
i checked out a sangha a few months ago
that just wasn't the right fit it wasn't
like the particular uh lineage of
buddhism that really resonates with me
but i finally found one in the area and
i'm really stoked about it well i'd hear
it man yeah so how was your summer break
it was good it was good i took a few
little trips uh anniversary trip with my
wife uh we
also took a trip to pinehurst with her
siblings just to hang out catch up with
them
uh and took a trip to columbus um maybe
like
three or four weeks ago uh to do dave
tate's table talk podcast which was
fantastic their facility is so sick uh
dave is a very cool very nice guy just
great experience all around
um and also
i
have spent the summer productively with
making content so one of the things
that's been
kind of weighing on me for a while now
is just as we've added more and more
parts to the business and just more and
more businesses
my my time to to write and make free
content has been severely curtailed and
so so my output has been
just horrifically down the last like
three or four years uh relative to
previous also going to grad school
during that time window
also did not uh help with the amount of
time i had to write
uh but i i've gotten back in a pretty
good groove over the summer getting um
averaging like one
free like high quality long form uh
article coming out per month
which uh i i feel pretty good about
that's
uh approximately 5x uh output relative
to the the previous four-year baseline
uh so
you know now that the podcast is coming
back and i'll be preparing for that on a
weekly basis
i
think that i'll still keep writing
consistently we'll see but
at least the last like five or six weeks
have have been pretty good in the
content department um and i feel good
about that good stuff um all right so
let's answer some we had some question
threads on facebook in the stronger by
science community group and then also on
the stronger by science subreddit
um the first one
is from anthony and the question is
uh
you know anthony enjoy has enjoyed
hearing some of our stories about freak
athletes
um
and he was basically wondering if we had
any additional ones do you have any
freak athletes that you'd like to uh
to discuss
yeah sure so um in a previous episode in
his his question directly reference this
uh one of the stronger by science
coaches aaron um used to coach at a
facility that did a lot of off-season
prep for nfl players
and one of the stories he told was about
maurice jones drew and how he refused to
do upper body training because his arms
would get too big too quick and he
couldn't carry a football like cradle it
well anymore aaron thought that that was
[ __ ] and so maurice jones drew said
okay cool like let's give it six weeks
and in six weeks he put like three
inches on his arms and
like he was a little guy i think it was
like five six five seven relatively
short arms kind of made a show about how
the football didn't cradle as well in
there anymore and aaron said well i
guess you're right your arms do get too
big um
so for a
certainly uh less famous example but
someone who i think
could have been like an nfl caliber
athlete had he started sports younger uh
is my friend easy from high school so
uh easy moved over to america from
nigeria i think when he was 14 or 15
and he was just he was just real skinny
he's like 5 11 6 foot
and i think he was like
maybe 130 so really really skinny guy
uh
into skateboarding didn't ever seem
particularly athletic i leave for
college
i come back for for summer break like
two years later
and uh walk into travis smash's gym i
had a uh an internship set up for that
summer
i walk in and i see easy and like i i
rode the bus with easy like i knew him
well i knew what he looked like and it
took me like
15-20 seconds to place who this guy was
because he'd gone from like
130 to 210 in about 18 months
and and we're talking all muscle like he
was still very lean and turns out he
just didn't know that like you had to
eat food because his family was like
quite impoverished in nigeria and when
he moved over here like those dietary
habits kind of came along with him so
like a
like two of his meals per day i think he
said like he would eat lunch at school
and then for breakfast he'd have like
half a ramen noodle packet and then for
dinner he'd have the other half of a
ramen noodle packet
and i don't think i i don't think in
america his situation was such that he
had to eat like that that was just like
what a normal amount of food was to him
so he got into lifting and people
convinced him to finally start eating
more food and
like he he probably put on about 60
pounds of muscle in about a year and a
half because like his his body was just
growing into the size that it could have
been all along
uh and in the process like he got his
vertical up to 44 45 inches he ran a sub
4 4 laser timed 40. um he just had some
of the most
effortless speed and leaping ability
i've ever seen like he was he was
putting up like nfl combine numbers
again with like
maybe 18 months of training uh and not
really even focused on jumping and
sprinting that much like just getting
under the bar doing some training got
him to like world class speed and
explosiveness
the problem
was he didn't play sports growing up and
so he was and i assume still is just
hilariously uncoordinated so like as as
he started growing into that athleticism
people started looking and being like
dude you could be
a ridiculous slot receiver let's just
let's just figure out how to catch a
football and you're you're gonna have a
good thing going
and uh he could not figure out how to
catch a football yeah um
but yeah so
in like i think
i think he was like very much born into
it like he he's also mentioned that i
think his like third or fourth cousin is
ocu manura like if if you watched
football back in the day defensive end
for the new york giants so like he's
he's got those jeans in his family um
but yeah
crazy athlete should have started
playing sports younger yeah
yeah i'm going to stay on the football
theme okay to answer this question and
that i think there were a lot of
football related questions there were
which is great the season's coming up
yeah it's august i'm all excited about
it i'm ready for football big time
um i also think that that's kind of a a
natural thing uh in america is like
if you
know a freak athlete you you almost
assume like in what way would you play
football right you know you so you might
you might uh say like oh man you'd be an
incredible lineman or a slot receiver
but it's always
uh football always seems to be the
default context yeah you know unless
they're like seven feet tall yeah so um
staying on the football theme uh
one athlete i genuinely don't know his
name it was a brief encounter
but i was hanging out in a facility
where a lot of athletes were preparing
for the nfl combine
it was like kind of a structured program
where pretty
pretty
elite scouts um or are pretty elite um
prospects we're kind of gathering there
to train together under a really highly
esteemed coach who specialized in
combine prep uh and and so there are
people from all over the country and i
was there just kind of helping out doing
some nutrition stuff
and
uh i just i had a brief conversation i
was
one of the people present during this
conversation with one of the athletes
who looked like he could
the next day just go to any natural pro
bodybuilding show and win
uh without
a moment of preparation for it
like he just he just looked like a
statue it was incredible uh but he was
preparing for the combine he was a
running back
and it was like three in the afternoon
and we were like hey you know what'd you
have for breakfast and he looked at us
like
first of all i have no idea but second
of all that is the most irrelevant
question i have ever heard in my entire
life like it was almost like where is
this coming from yeah uh it'd be like if
we walked up and said hey what's your
favorite color yeah so he was so out of
tune with nutrition he didn't even
understand why a person would ask
what do you have for breakfast today so
he yeah he's not it's it's like asking
what's your zodiac sign right yeah yeah
so so it's again three in the afternoon
he's been exercising for the entirety of
the day
and we said what'd you have for
breakfast nothing what do you have for
lunch nothing what have you been
drinking or snacking on
in this marathon training session
absolutely nothing it's 3pm he's been
training for like four hours and he's
had nothing but water and we're like
what are you gonna have when you get
home he's like i have no idea like maybe
like peanut butter and jelly
um and yeah like just to see
someone with that physique who
most people if they saw his physique
would say
he's obviously on steroids like there's
no question and like
this guy doesn't even pay attention to a
single thing he eats like the the idea
that he's you know
doing some kind of intricate you know
doping protocol is just so beyond absurd
in this scenario but
just yeah hanging out around people
preparing for the combine changes your
perspective about what a freak athlete
is uh just because yeah there are people
who show up and before they start
optimizing a single thing you're just
like
i i could never
fathom getting there in a million years
like like that physical skill set
uh another story i went to school uh
there's a guy on my wrestling and
football team named josh klein
uh and it's hard to explain like i i
can't give you like a bench press number
or a 40 time that would really convey
why he was a freak athlete but
he was our heavyweight you know so he
would normally walk around around 275 or
280 but he would wrestle like he weighed
130 pounds like he was so
light on his feet and like graceful
and just the way he moved didn't make
sense relative to his body mass
it's like a young shack
exactly yeah it's like a young shack
where you're like
why are why do you have the footwork and
like ball skills
how could this happen at your size you
know
uh but yeah so he he just was so light
on his feet and had so much
agility and coordination it just didn't
look right uh and then he he went into
the nfl and bulked well into the 300s
and did not lose a single ounce of that
athleticism so like it was just insane
it was like a 300 pound like ballerina
almost uh so he was a freak athlete and
he's got at least one super bowl ring to
show for it
um and then another guy i'm not going to
name him because it
the the story
reflects negative negatively upon him
and
uh it's all second-hand information so
i don't want to like disparage him
without knowing for certain but
there there was a guy to local school
when i was in high school who um ended
up playing running back in the nfl
uh
all the the major league baseball teams
were just like beating his door down
when he was in high school they wanted
him to go straight to the major league
baseball draft
so like he could have been a pro
immediately in baseball but was like i'd
rather be in the nfl instead yeah like
he was that that kind of guy
uh but the story goes that the strength
coach had a sign on the door of the
weight room uh because scouts were
coming from all over to you know to to
talk to him and and you know see if they
could watch some workouts and stuff and
the strength coach allegedly put a sign
on the door that said don't ask me about
him i'm not going to talk about him i'm
not going
uh
you know
vouch for him in any way at all because
he skips all his workouts and he doesn't
train hard
uh
and it just didn't matter like yeah like
to me that the craziest thing about a
freak athlete is not what people
of course it's incredible to see what
people achieve when they
optimize everything and they're just
like full you know
full speed ahead nutrition training etc
everything optimized but something that
that really uh just shocks me is when
someone just has that kind of
raw
uh set of physical abilities where it's
like without even really
bothering to try it's like boom
immediately major league baseball
and every
major college in the country is trying
to get him to come play running back
like it's just
it we played him in football and being
on the field so he was playing
quarterback at the time and i was
playing on defense
every moment of that game you were just
thinking i hope he doesn't embarrass me
like i hope he doesn't find an
opportunity to square up with me one on
one because that is not gonna go well
for me whatsoever yeah um but yeah so
absolutely incredible athlete along
those lines there was kind of a similar
question uh related to nfl so
if every nfl athlete it's really cool
that we're like 20 minutes into the
episode and we've already lost all of
our european listeners we'll get them
back we'll get them back
so let's do this one really quick
really quick if if every nfl athlete
were to compete in bodybuilding
how many would you guess would have the
ability to make the olympia stage
yeah so um
since it's a since it's a how many
question i interpreted it quite
literally um so i think it's constrained
by the size of the olympia stage uh in
the most recent olympia competition in
open bodybuilding at least it was a max
of of 16 competitors so whatever the
number is in my opinion it has to be
below 16. um
and yeah like i think most of the the
freakiest physical specimens in the us
do kind of just get filtered into the
nfl um
you know because of its cultural impact
so many people play football growing up
etc etc but you know there's a lot of
the world that does bodybuilding where
people wouldn't be getting filtered into
the nfl and so i don't think uh i don't
think current nfl athletes would take up
all 16 slots on the stage but i think
somewhere between
maybe like 10 and 13 uh with with my
best guess being 12
um
but yeah i i do think that people who
are
presently in the nfl would largely
dominate the olympia stage if
we lived in a bizarro world where no one
cared about football but
like
non-drug-free bodybuilding was the
biggest sport on the planet
yeah like if uh instead of
you know everybody talking about the
game on sunday if if everybody was just
focused on bodybuilding yeah uh which is
just a world that would be difficult to
imagine just because bodybuilding over
the years has become such a niche kind
of endeavor yeah there was a minute
there where it was on like espn like
every year
there was a while there when power
lifting was on espn
the mountaineer cup yeah yeah but um
anyway yeah i agree i think it i would
expect at least half of those slots
would be people who otherwise would have
gone to the nfl but like the incentives
are such that if
if you were like well i could go to the
nfl or be you know a pro bodybuilder you
got to go with the nfl oh yeah uh
it just the the incentives are so
mismatched you know uh yeah i i would
love to see mass monster aaron donald oh
yeah cause he's or or miles garrett oh
miles is crazy dude he
i i think i think give him an off season
to train
he would probably
place like top 10 at the olympia anyways
yeah no he probably would so yeah give
him like give him like five years to
blast all of the peptides he can get his
hands on not have to worry about drug
testing yeah i mean come on come on yeah
all right we've got
yeah you want to read this one yeah so
uh
uh darian buford galleon asks uh
i i would like to speak about your
relationship with animals and pets do
you have any home gym mascots for your
home facility or outside of the home
facility my home gym has several feline
motivational coaches but they hate it
when the weights drop
so
do we have dogs or cats and
are we dog or cat people
yeah so
uh i don't have a home gym mascot
because i don't have a home gym
uh
i i quite like getting out of the house
to train uh i think part of that is
being you know fully work from home even
since like pre-pandemic
um yeah to me getting out of the house
and going to train was always something
i look forward to so i i have not made
any effort to put together a home gym
but but there was a direct question in
here
dog cats or dogs um and if you had asked
me
years ago i would have very quickly said
i'm a dog person i don't like cats but
my girlfriend
came with a cat uh she has izzy the cat
who is now living around the house being
a good kitten
uh yeah at first i was a bit uh
a bit hesitant about interacting with
izzy the cat i i'd never spent any time
around cats and so i really had no frame
of reference for like
how do you interact with a cat and what
are cats
supposed to do like to me
i always viewed them as um
as if they were supposed to be the same
thing as a dog and so within that
context a lot of times people were like
oh i hate cats because i was expecting a
dog and this isn't a dog you know
but uh
izzy and i have become very close um
every day around noon she gets uh
we have a routine where we cuddle at
noon and if i if i don't come and cuddle
with izzy the cat for five minutes she
gets all agitated so i don't understand
how or why that became a tradition but
like now around noon she comes and is
like hey it's it's time
but yeah so izzy and i are very close
buddies and yeah i just i never would
have expected that i would
uh
yeah i always thought that i was very
strictly a dog person who actually quite
disliked cats
but after you spend a little bit of time
with them you start to realize that part
of the fun with a cat is just
trying to understand their extremely
peculiar little personalities and quirks
but yeah izzy's she's a blast i love
having her around the house and i have
noticed that uh
on the road to enlightenment i've gotten
a lot more into nature and a lot more in
touch with animals in general so i think
that also helped me say like
it doesn't really make sense to
choose cats versus dogs as a preference
because like they're just different and
you can enjoy hanging out with animals
so like man i probably have i probably
have a conversation with a frog three
days a week hell yeah uh
because we have these frogs and i have a
pool in the backyard are you sure these
aren't toads and you're not conversing
with them after licking their stomachs
no these are frogs okay and we've got a
pool in the backyard which came with the
house and i wish it didn't because
you know
taking care of a pool is kind of a pain
but anyway uh
these frogs like to hang out in the pool
but it's not good for them like
frogs have very porous skin yeah that
takes in like stuff from the outside
environment and so like three days a
week i come to clean out the pool
there's a frog swimming around and i'm
like dude
uh you're welcome to it like i'm not
saying you're not welcome here but it's
not good for you to be soaking up
a bunch of salt water and chlorine like
this is not in line with your interests
and goals yeah so about three days a
week i have a heart to heart with the
frogs but where i live is awesome i'm
kind of out in the country now so yeah i
have all these turtles and deer and
frogs and and you name it out there
which is great nice but to answer the
question dogs cats they're both awesome
uh but yeah what do you think greg
yeah so i i do have a home gym mascot uh
pet dog his name is oswald he's
absolutely tremendous he's 10 years old
now but he still acts
the same way as as he did when we got
him when he was two uh very high energy
theoretically a tibetan terrier mix
don't know if that's the case tibetan
terriers are supposed to be relatively
calm oswald is the is the furthest thing
from it um and he he does come down in
the basement to work out with lindsay
and i when we train
um but he hates it like i i don't know
why he does this to himself
and it's not it's not even like the
weights making noise like even if we're
just doing like a dumbbell or like
kettlebell workout or something like
something where not much noise is being
made
he still
despises it um and i think it's because
he thinks we're in pain and he's he's
concerned for us
uh but yeah he he just
always comes down to the basement with
us when we work out hates every minute
of it and refuses to go anywhere else
um but yeah he's he's great oswald is is
a tremendous dog uh and i would say
overall in terms of the cat person dog
person question
i am sl
so i am uh
due to physiological necessity
more of a dog person
growing up i was
i was roughly split i would say i
preferred dogs also very much liked cats
one of the best pets i ever had was this
cat named todd who was
absolutely tremendous i have a ton of
great todd stories um
also one of my one of my roommates in
college had a cat named jacopo who was
also just a tremendous cat uh and and i
hope uh i hope he's doing well but uh i
became allergic to cats as an adult so i
don't know if i've told this story on
the podcast before but i got kicked out
of my house in college and had to spend
a summer living in lindsay's basement
and her basement was where
one of their family's cats spent most of
its time so like i was sleeping on the
couch which is where this cat also just
hung out all the time so i basically
spent an entire summer sleeping in cat
dander
and
that process i believe made me allergic
to cats and so now i'm incredibly
allergic to cats so i i still like them
i still appreciate them
but until
i find the time and interest to go back
to an allergist and start getting
allergy shots again this time for cats
uh
i i have to enjoy and appreciate them
from a distance yeah
one thing that
never ceases to amaze me with cat
with cats is just their
their athleticism is insane yeah like
the way that they can jump the way that
they can balance like
uh one one of my exercise physiology
professors back in the day was was a a
huge cat person and he tried to like
recruit me over to that side
and at this point i was still very
hesitant but he was like dude you claim
to like muscle how could you like muscle
and not be just absolutely captivated by
cats yeah because like yeah they are
just explosive little killing machines
they're incredible yeah it's pretty wild
uh okay moving on um we've got a
question do you know how to pronounce
that name
i have no idea okay uh pair p-e-r
um
but uh the question is what is the
coolest country that you've been to and
is it cooler than america
yeah so it's it's hard to
i would say circumspectly answer this
question because
the longest i've ever been in another
country
is like maybe a week and a half
something like that uh so i've only
gotten relatively short-term relatively
slanted views of other countries like
when we travel
um
when when possible like if we're
traveling for a seminar or a conference
or something um
we we prefer staying with some of the
people organizing it just so we can get
a better view of what life is like in a
particular place for people who actually
live there from day day to day instead
of you know staying in a hotel or resort
and just just exclusively getting the
tourist experience but you know even
even living like even staying in a place
for like a week and a half that that
still just gives you a very very small
view
of what life is like in a particular
place um
but with that with that caveat out of
the way
um like there have been
i i think everywhere we've been has been
very cool like i i enjoy travel
um but just in terms of places that i
would say are cooler than america
i would have to say probably iceland was
the coolest
just in terms of how
well the society seems to be run so like
from from the outside looking in
like it's see
one would assume that it would just
absolutely suck being in iceland um
in part because like they don't have
that many natural resources like they
they can do some renewable energy stuff
with all of the all of the geothermal
stuff uh and they have good fishing
waters off of the coast
but like that's about it like they don't
have that much arable land they don't
have that many like natural resources um
so they they're very dependent on the
outside world they have to import a lot
of stuff and iceland is kind of a long
way away from everywhere so uh
like things just cost more because they
all have to be shipped in kind of like
kind of like hawaii like people who
visited hawaii they're like oh why is
everything so expensive well it's in the
middle of the ocean like your stuff had
to get here um so it seems like it
should be a country with uh a lot of
cards stacked against it but it seems
remarkably well run so for starters uh
we we
spent like we we stayed in reykjavik and
then just kind of like ventured out from
there but i really enjoyed uh just being
in reykjavik like it's uh a very
beautiful walkable city like you can you
can walk across the entire city um
like there are no parts of it that i can
remember that aren't pretty easily
accessible either on foot or by bike
from anywhere else in the city which
is great um
so it's really easy to get around and
also like
given all of those caveats i i mentioned
up top about how much the deck seems to
be stacked against it just purely from a
geography and natural resource
perspective uh the standards of living
seem to be quite high
and uh like levels of of poverty seem to
be quite low like like virtually
non-existent um and so
given
given all of the
like given the hand that iceland was
dealt their ability to play those cards
and
come up with at least what appeared to
me to be a very
high standard of living in
well-functioning society is is very
impressive
and with
how many resources america has just
makes me think
damn
damn
i i won't elaborate on that further but
yeah jesus [ __ ] christ
yeah uh so we we went to iceland
together yeah uh and just based on like
pure scenery um
and like natural beauty
i thought iceland was uh really
spectacular like i iceland is just a
place like no other in terms of
yeah i mean just the uh
the natural scenery is you you kind of
feel like you're on a different planet
coming from uh the southeastern united
states and then going to iceland where
you know in the southeast u.s um you
know a lot of forests and stuff around
here
and you go out to iceland and it's you
know volcanic rock and moss and yeah
it's just uh it was it was really really
cool to see
uh everything that iceland has to offer
in terms of just the natural world
um
i also agree i thought iceland seemed
from an outside perspective
like it was a really uh well-run country
with a
a really thoughtfully organized society
um
and that's another thing that uh that's
something that i also noticed and
appreciated about finland when i was
there uh i was only there for a few days
so like
who am i to determine which societies
are are run best and which cultures are
you know but like i felt like i really
fit in really well
in iceland and in finland in terms of
just like
i think one of the
one of the things that struck me about
finland just to kind of like give a
concrete example
i got on the train in finland you could
hear a pin drop
the entire time like i i picked up very
quickly the idea that it was considered
a bit rude to make like virtually any
noise at all and as someone who loves
quiet and solitude i was like dude this
is the best
uh but yeah in finland people were were
very uh kind and polite that i
interacted with but they generally kept
to themselves and uh it was just a nice
like quiet kind kind of vibe there that
i really liked so um
and they they freaking
everyone i talked to there just seemed
to really appreciate both well
that's probably a dumb thing so i was
there for a
science
conference
at a university that was like very
focused on exercise science so as far as
i can tell everyone in finland loves
science exercise and exercise science
but i probably got an extremely biased
perspective on that so that's why like
as i was saying i was like that's very
stupid for me to conclude that yeah uh
but yeah i had a great time there
nonetheless
good deal man uh so next question is
from daniel guetta uh if you had to give
up gluten or dairy for the rest of your
life which would you pick
i'll go first i would definitely give up
gluten of those two
not that i have any problem with gluten
i certainly don't it's
uh you read wheat belly over the summer
break and you're terrified did not um
but no it i i definitely enjoy working
with gluten and cooking with it like
it's uh
culinarily type
culinarily quite interesting
but
i don't know like i i just don't
i don't like bread that much i guess uh
i like tortillas but i don't know like
most most
products with gluten
are either like take it or leave at
things for me or things that i
like but if i if someone told me like
you can never have
a tortilla again i'd say oh well
that sucks but like i'll i'll live my
life um
but i so like my my staple starch is
rice like i'd say
for for the last like five years
probably eighty percent of the
carbohydrate i've consumed has come from
rice so like yeah like gluten wheat like
i
i could do without it i would not want
to do without dairy products because
while
and especially like with the current
markets like uh there are a lot of solid
gluten free options on the market i
myself don't buy them for my own
purposes but uh there's someone in the
family with celiac disease when i cook
for them um
you know a decade ago like gluten-free
noodles absolutely sucked now they're
they're okay uh gluten-free bread still
has a ways to go but it's it's much
better than it used to be so like yeah i
could give up gluten but
like vegetarian and vegan cheese
alternatives aren't aren't good
um
and like like plant milks like oat milk
soy milk whatever um
some of those have gotten quite good
just as standalone products but i don't
think they're
really true dairy substitutes uh and
also just a lot of the a lot of the
desserts that i particularly like are
dairy based desserts so i
like cheesecake and ice cream are one
and two for me
um
and like yeah you can make non-dairy
versions of them but they they just
don't scratch the same itch
so yeah if someone said you can never
have sandwich bread again i'd say ah
that sucks if someone said you can never
have ice cream again like dairy ice
cream
i think for like a week i'd say yeah
that's fine but then at some point i'm
gonna get that itch and i'm gonna want
[ __ ] ice cream and if i couldn't have
dairy i would be gutted so yeah i
wouldn't want to give up either of them
but of the two i i'd have an easier time
with gluten yeah this is going to be a
rare instance of disagreement here um so
i
not only would give up dairy but i'm
actually uh
kind of in the final process of giving
up dairy uh like
uh many many months ago i started eating
a vegetarian diet and then i looked at
my like day to day diet and i was like
would i miss the dairy in this at all
and i ultimately reached the conclusion
not really yeah so at this point like i
still have some remaining like protein
bars and whey products that are sitting
around
um but
once i kind of tear through all the
stuff i already have
i'm pretty much gonna be on a dairy-free
diet anyway um not not
i always have to give this caveat it has
nothing to do with health or performance
or anything like that you know sometimes
people will do all sorts of
scaremongering about you know dairy does
all these terrible things that's not the
case nutritionally i think dairy has a
lot to offer um but but for me it's just
kind of a continuation of
um you know transitioning to a
vegetarian diet purely for reasons
related to just uh animal welfare stuff
and things like that so uh yeah dairy's
for me it's such a minimal part of my
diet already that i just looked at i was
like i don't think i'm gonna miss that
at all um but i am going to uh consume
dairy on occasion most like so like if
someone's preparing a meal for me
like i'm very strictly vegetarian but if
there's dairy in that meal i don't care
like i'm gonna still consume it if if
i'm with friends and we're like hey
we're gonna go out to a restaurant i'll
say hey
you know as long as there's vegetarian
options i'll be good with it i'm not
going to worry about eating dairy in
that situation but in my kind of like
base day-to-day diet that i consume
regularly at this point dairy is like
the amount that was in my diet was
pretty negligible and i was like i could
easily swap that out and not miss it so
uh so yeah dairy's on the way out for me
gluten
it's one of those things like i could
live without gluten
and i could live without dairy but i
cannot live without gluten and dairy
yeah like to me that's where the
question starts to get extremely like
i don't know where i'd go from there
like vegetarian without dairy and gluten
uh that'd be tough a lot of tofu and
rice it would be a lot of tofu and rice
and some beans yeah and that'd be about
it
all right let's move on to some of the
reddit questions and let's try to get
through these relatively efficiently
in an expeditious manner uh so starting
out i just scrolled all over the place
where are we here uh i'll i'll read i'll
read this one in so uh the most upvoted
one i believe was by logan fitness
asking what is the most luxurious thing
you own that you don't ever want to live
without for example uh
these are somewhat weird examples a
japanese bidet toilet seat why's it
gotta be japanese i mean do they make
the best bidets i have no idea not a
bidet guy
a towel warmer a two thousand dollar
coffee machine etc
so what are what are your what are your
luxury items eric
well
i i stole one from your answer because
you answered it first um but
like as anyone
watching this if it becomes a
visual piece of content as anyone can
see we both have very nice computers um
and so and i was pestering you to get a
nice computer for like two years correct
that is correct uh but i'm stubborn and
i'm old and
i don't like new things that's fair so
uh but you know we work on our computers
we make content of all sorts you know
visual audio etc so having a good
computer is kind of a uh
it's still a luxury but it's a somewhat
necessary luxury with the things we do
but aside from that for me it would be
my car
so i tend to be very frugal
and i don't get a lot of joy from
material possessions
so like my normal default setting would
be like if i was going to get a car i'd
go to a used car lot and get just the
biggest piece of crap on the lot and say
yes that matches my consuming habits
very well
but i did have to get a new car
uh
a few years ago at this point and i
started thinking about it and i realized
like
i mean i still bought a used car um but
i was like you know i'm
at that time i was in my late 20s
generally in good health
uh living in rural america which means i
drive a lot and i was like
probably the biggest like realistic
immediate threat to my health and safety
would be an auto accident yeah you know
what i mean like it at that point i was
like of all these for young reasonably
healthy people like accidents primarily
car accidents drug overdoses and
suicides like those are the three things
that are going to take you out right and
so i i don't mean to make it too morbid
a conversation but i was like
my natural tendency was to be ultra
frugal with my car purchase and i was
like dude i drive a lot in like very icy
mountain roads like i drive in the
mountains in the winter every single
year and i've had some really dicey
situations
driving a 2004 toyota camry with totally
bald tires
and like halfway functioning brakes
through an icy mountain road and i'm
like i shouldn't have been doing that
like that doesn't make any sense yeah so
for me i think it makes sense to spend a
little bit of extra cash on a car
mostly because
the really cheap cars that were made 10
or 15 years ago the safety features that
have come out in the years since are
actually very impressive like the first
time i drove my new car which is a 2017
uh which i got in 2020
so it was three years old at the time
but i felt like i was driving like a
spaceship i was like dude look when i
slam on the brakes all these things
light up and i hear sensors and stuff
and it and it actually stops and it
stops yeah dude my parent it got to the
point like just to
to reinforce how bad it got uh it got to
the point my parents wouldn't get in my
car
like
they visited and i offered to drive and
i noticed that they kept very forcefully
saying no no we'll drive yeah and
eventually it came out they weren't just
like being polite it was like yeah we're
not
we're not we don't feel comfortable in
your car
so yeah my car is definitely my luxury
my luxury item what about you well in
like to be clear
not really even a luxury item it's like
a
it's a 2017 rav4 yeah
yeah like there was there was another
question that i think maybe we're not
gonna answer about like
what what's your dream car like it's you
know it's not even like a super
expensive car
no it's just like a modern car
yeah it is a car with uh modern safety
upgrades but yeah yeah so i i bought a
three-year-old
toyota rav4
and yeah jumping ahead it's my dream car
i i'm going to stick with rav4s for as
long as they keep making them nice um
but but yeah i finally
that was like the first thing that i
actually spent a substantial amount of
money on myself and was like i think
that was worth it yeah yeah yeah so so
my my answer as eric already alluded to
was also my computer um
yeah i mean for for working online uh
the worse your computer is the more
headaches you have to deal with on a
daily basis so i i view it almost as
like
yeah it's it's not a necessity but it's
the closest thing to being one
um
and then honestly i i had a hard time
coming up with other things uh because i
am also
i i wouldn't even say i'm that frugal i
just have cheap tastes like uh
when when people have previously gotten
me
like
a nicer article of clothing or something
like that i don't like it i wear cheap
clothes from walmart because they feel
better um
so yeah like i
i'm i'm a cheap person overall so i i
had a hard time coming up with a
luxurious thing that i didn't want to go
without uh and when i was initially
typing on the outline i couldn't come up
with anything
but last night
one of the experiences of my nighttime
routine did remind me of something that
i wouldn't want to live without and
that's really nice towels
so i'm
a relatively large person and i'm a very
hairy person and so when i get done
showering there is
i think approximately a gallon and a
half of water clinging to my body
and like i had used very cheap towels my
entire life
and like i always got i mean not dry but
dry enough so i was like what's you know
this is fine
dry is a very temporary state when you
live in north carolina in august yeah
yeah that that's the thing like do i
really need to get all of the water off
of me i'm gonna get a glisten going soon
anyways
um
but yeah i know so so uh my wife got
some
they're not they're not even called
towels what are they called i think
they're called bath sheets
but they're they're essentially
extra large
very fluffy hyper-absorbent towels
and they're so nice
um and so like yeah i i can still like
make do with cheap towels obviously like
i'm totally fine with it but i i really
do like having the nice towels it's a
it's a nice little upgrade for my life
yeah
all right here's one that that i know we
agree on yeah a question from mitch who
would win in a fight a greg sized eric
or an eric sized greg
yeah so it would definitely be a greg
sized eric i think under under normal
rules though i do have a twist to that
that i will reveal after you give your
answer or reasoning
um
but yeah i know so you you have a
wrestling background like i i did a
couple wrestling camps uh but never
wrestled competitively like i i know
some some basics but i'm sure it's like
the stuff that everyone learns in their
first two weeks of wrestling um so you
you would have the technique advantage
over me
and like weight classes exist for a
reason um
like what what do you weigh these days
uh 170. yeah so
a a greg sized eric would have like a 50
pound weight advantage um so yeah i
think
i think most of the time you would you
would win that uh
that run-in
yeah i mean
so
you are
bigger and stronger i have more
technical experience uh so so it's
pretty straightforward i think for this
answer but the one thing that a lot of
people forget about though wrestling is
a lot of wrestlers think like oh i
wrestle and therefore i'm a good fighter
but sometimes people punch you in fights
and wrestling is an interesting set of
skills because you get used to
a semi like combat type activity
with a very
controlled uh there is no threat of
getting punched or kicked in the head
and so that shapes the type of things
you do as a wrestler right you you would
not go into a ufc cage and do like a
normal
uh wrestling takedown because you would
get need in the face and you would be
unconscious immediately right yeah so uh
wrestling got me most of the way there
but i had a very very brief stint as a
bouncer in college
uh and during that brief stint i caught
more than a couple random like punches
uh because like yeah if you say like hey
i'm gonna need you to leave then all of
a sudden people start punching you like
that's how security at a bar works so um
i think my wrestling experience combined
with
figuring out how to not get punched in
the face quite as frequently i think
that's a really nice combination of
skill sets to marry up nice so the the
wrinkle i want to throw in is one i
think in a
kind of traditional fight
i don't think an eric sized greg
could win the fight but i i do think as
long as our our general physical
attributes other than size scaled
i do i do think there's a chance that i
could i could fight it to a draw and the
reason i say that is i i have
very good grip strength and if i can
like if i can get like a hold locked in
uh
you're you're not getting out yeah and
so like i i don't think i'd be able to
like take a greg sized eric down like
get top position and just like ground
and pound or like get in a rear naked
choke or something like that but i think
if i could just get close enough to get
my arms wrapped around you
like
it would basically just be a war of
attrition like look you're you're never
going to create enough space to do any
damage i'm just going to hold on until
you give up
um
so i think that that's a possibility
also
this question didn't specify the rules
of of the fight
like it didn't say who would win in an
octagon and i'm very confident that i
have more firearms experience than you
so
if this is like a deadliest game type
situation yeah i don't like my chances i
mean
in eric's size greg would also just be a
smaller target so if anything that would
be an advantage yeah uh but i
i hope it never comes to that yeah no
the grip strength thing is very real uh
every now and then um
in my wrestling days
you know the match would begin you go to
the center of the mat you shake hands
they blow the whistle
there were more than a couple occasions
where you shake hands with somebody and
immediately go oh [ __ ] here we go yeah
and you're like it doesn't mean it's
over but it means it's not gonna be fun
and it's not gonna be as easy as i
thought yeah you know um but yeah every
now and then you'll just find someone
who's like
they're not even like physically that
imposing but they shake your hand you go
oh [ __ ] yeah like this is gonna suck
yeah um all right moving on here
all right uh exalt the farmer asks what
is the best best method for starting a
campfire
um
so this
inspired me to actually google what are
the different campfire shapes
i like the appearance the aesthetic
appeal of a a more cone-shaped fire
but after doing thorough research i i
realize it's probably not the best route
it works it it works but um
there are a lot of very nerdy articles
about the scientifically optimal fire
and apparently the cone-shaped one is
not the one that's the one i always do
because i think it looks like your kind
of typical campfire i say oh that looks
lovely i'll do that
um but this is a skill i'm going to be
honest i really need to get better at
building campfires because like i said
the rav4 is all decked out it's ready to
become a camping vehicle
and
i'm i'm gonna be making a lot of fires
so i have a lot of room for improvement
here
all right so i i do have a strong
opinion about this i've made
a lot of campfires and also just a lot
of fires in general in my day uh i had a
a little a little pyro phase in high
school um and never convicted of arson
correct um
and and i didn't burn that many things
of value like
i i think i think it would have been a
misdemeanor at worst anyway um
so the the method that i tend to use
that works quite well is i use the
i guess what i call the square chimney
method so obviously like the basics are
there you want to start small work big
you don't start with big logs you start
with like tiny little sticks leaves get
something going work up to a little bit
larger sticks etc etc so
in terms of like an organizing principle
within that
what you want to do is you want to try
to find some sticks that have a diameter
of i would say
between like half an inch and an inch
and a half to begin with
and you just stack them up like lincoln
logs so you're gonna put
two parallel to each other maybe about
six inches apart six inches to a foot
apart and then you're going to get two
more uh put those on top of the first
two perpendicular to them so now you're
you're kind of looking down at a square
and then you just repeat the process
over and over and over until you've
maybe got a chimney of relatively dry
sticks of a somewhat uniform diameter
again between like half an inch and an
inch and a half
that's built up
like maybe a foot high give or take
and then from there you start the fire
with the little stuff inside of that
chimney so you're gonna get
dry leaves very tiny little sticks get a
fire going i'm not going to do any of
the hardcore stuff where you try to like
start it with flynn and steel like you
know i'm going to get stuff that's small
enough that you can ignite it with just
a lighter or a match
and then just start building that little
fire with the little stuff
in the middle of that chimney of sticks
and then gradually what that's going to
do is it's going to dry out the larger
sticks and then eventually the ones on
the bottom will dry out enough get hot
enough that they ignite and then at that
point it's it's fire on easy mode
because once you have
a pretty decent flame going with sticks
that are about an inch in diameter at
that point you can start more
aggressively scaling up the size of
stuff you're burning and and you've got
a pretty good fire going so that's
that's the method i use and it's the
method i recommend
all right good stuff do you mind if we
skip ahead a couple to make sure that we
get to the good stuff toward the end
yeah yeah let's do it i was thinking
that the next one that i'd like to see
we already talked a little bit about
cars uh
fun fact is that we both drive rav4s
though i feel like we're missing out a
pretty good sponsorship opportunity
there i feel like toyota should be
calling any day here and to be clear uh
so like
as i mentioned previously i'm just not
that
interested by material things
you got a rav4
and then my car broke and i was like
round four that looks pretty good like
that was kind of the entirety of my
decision making so
uh but yeah so let's go ahead and move
on to the um this one's a big question
if you weren't doing what you do now
what would you be doing with your life
any other passions or near misses
when it comes to other ways your life
could have gone
that you think of
yeah so i'll i'll start um i i was i was
very hard-headed as a kid and i didn't
really plan ahead for anything
if i
could go back with a more
circumspect and mature approach to life
planning at 17 years old
i probably would have gone
into something related to engineering
like i think that's
more compatible with how my brain works
honestly the fact that i that i'm mostly
a writer like that's most of what i do
that's insane like that it doesn't
and i don't mean insane as in wow i did
something impressive insane as in that
was a stupid decision because like
that's
that's one of the things that i i
struggle with the most like i'm not
naturally good with words and i only got
decent at writing just through
a lot of practice and in a very patient
editor
but yeah so i i
think i probably would have done
something related to to engineering uh
or maybe like computer science or
something that's like very like math and
logic oriented um
and the reason i didn't uh completely
true story i just didn't want to have to
relearn how to do calculus so i took uh
i took calc 2 sophomore year of high
school and when i was thinking about
college majors i was like [ __ ] if i do
something engineering related i'm going
to have to take more math classes and
like
it's been two years since i since i took
calc
and i just don't i don't want to relearn
like that seems hard and so i just
didn't so i went into college as a
history major um
and so
history was a very near miss i switched
majors to exercise science when i was
already in like the senior capstone
class for history yeah so had i not done
that i'd i'd probably be like a history
teacher history professor maybe like
museum curator type deal um and then
also uh another very close near miss was
uh still going into fitness
but just taking another route through
the industry i guess so after college i
had a job lined up uh coaching for
travis mash like back here in north
carolina uh lindsay had an internship
lined up in california and we decided to
go to california and so
you know we we were already married
didn't want to do a long-distance
marriage so job in north carolina wasn't
going to pan out
so yeah if if she didn't get that
internship i would have had a very
different entry point into the fitness
industry and and who knows where it
would have gone from there um and then
at this point i guess i also have
kind of another
escape hatch like if if the business
caved tomorrow just completely went up
in flames um
i've got my masters now
i
i if if nothing immediately materialized
i would potentially go back get my phd
and probably see what sort of good pain
industry job i could get with a phd in
the field um i'm i'm not at all
interested in in going the academic
route um so that that's something i
could probably do but realistically
if if everything just caved in around
our heads tomorrow
i i would probably just try to figure
out some other business i could start
and do that um
i don't do well with
uh with hierarchical power structures um
or you could just rephrase that i have
issues with authority like i
i
don't think i would do well with a boss
i've worked for people before and i know
this about myself i'm a bad employee
like
i think
i think i'm a decent boss but like i'm a
i'm a dog [ __ ] employee
um
so yeah i i would probably just figure
out
just some
some other business i could do where i
wouldn't have to have a boss i don't
know what that would be maybe lawn care
i did that for a while it was [ __ ]
fun i loved it um
or
i mean now that we're in raleigh like
there's there's a lot of uh wealthy
families who want to get their kids into
good colleges i used to have a uh sat
prep business back in the day that did
that did quite well might try to get
back into that that was very fun um
but yeah so
i i don't really know what route i would
go but but probably just start some
other business
yeah how about you
well uh growing up um
in my school
um there was this kind of
implied pressure where it was like if
you did pretty good
in like math and science stuff you were
supposed to say you wanted to be a
physician
and if you're doing pretty well on
basically anything else you say oh you
should go be a lawyer you know if you're
good at like writing or like
anything in like a history kind of area
anything that was very reading and
writing intensive
um
so based on that i kind of picked up on
the idea like oh i should i'm supposed
to try to be a physician
and then i got into college and there
were two things that scared me away from
that
first of all the prereqs looked terrible
like i just looked at the
lineup of coursework and i was like i
don't want to take half of those courses
second of all uh
i don't know how it works
internationally but
in the united states med school is hyper
competitive um and i was like i don't
know if i got
that fight in me right now that dog
exactly yeah i was like i don't think
i'm i'm up for that
uh so what i decided was like i i looked
at
professions that were in that general
like allied health
vicinity but had a prerequisite
coursework that was more compatible with
what i wanted to do
and so physical therapy looked like a
really intuitive fit and that was kind
of when i went to college and people
said what are you going to do i'd say
i'm going to be a physical therapist
like that was pretty set
but then you know stuff changes things
happen and you go a different route
a very near miss
as near a miss as you could get was
before i decided to work
at stronger by science
i had a job offer to be a professor
somewhere
to the point where it was like hey just
make the phone call say yes sign the
paper and you're good
and uh yeah so that was a very very near
miss and that's not to say like oh being
a professor is a bad job and it sucks
that's not the case but it was the wrong
thing for me at the wrong stage in my
life you know at that time being a
professor in hindsight
wasn't the right move for me
fortunately i can look back and say i
feel really good about the route that i
took
but yeah that was an extremely extremely
near miss because i yeah i mean it was
offer in hand
interview process was done all that
stuff so
um
in terms of you know if if the uh
business cave tomorrow
not really sure what i would do but
i am at a spot in life where i feel like
there are a lot of different very viable
paths that would be exciting and fun and
fulfilling so you know i'm not sweating
it too much my hope is that none of
those paths will ever need to be
utilized i mean your girlfriend has a
good job like you could you could just
put a ring on it go the trophy husband
route i could yeah that wouldn't be a
bad gig i was gonna say like when you
were talking about getting a phd and
going industry um
i would try to talk you into a different
phd honestly uh because like yeah my
girlfriend's phd is in uh if you get a
phd i'll just make it more general if
you get a phd in social psychology but
you have a good background with data
management and statistical analysis or
if you get a phd in quantitative
psychology
you are
very employable
in today's world like it is really
incredible you'll see people coming out
of those types of programs
and they're getting job offers almost in
like 10 different sectors 10 different
industries of just
there are so many uh industry jobs where
they say we want you to generally know
how humans think and behave and we want
you to be able to manage and analyze
data and if you can do those two things
you're very very employable so yeah if
you do go back for the phd i might try
to nudge you toward that one
yeah okay
um
all right uh so moving on
what we got a a question from
dick from richard
uh and the question is what is a piece
of modern technology or a gadget that
you simply reject
and you insist on doing things the way
that you've always done them without
this new technology or gadget
yeah so that that's very easy for me uh
and this this answer will probably make
some enemies because fans of these two
gadgets are very rabid they they love
them uh but i think that they're
completely pointless there's no reason
to have them unless you just don't have
an oven or stove uh and though and if
you don't you know you live in a studio
apartment without a kitchen very valid
reason to have these two pieces of
equipment otherwise i don't see the
point that is an instant pot and an air
fryer an instant pot is just a pressure
cooker like if you have a stove you can
just get a pressure cooker uh and
they're a lot cheaper than an instant
pot uh
and then an air fryer
i i don't know what people think an air
fryer is doing i
there's there there's
i think people think there's almost this
mystical quality about them that somehow
adjust with air it's going to produce
the same results as like deep frying
food which it simply doesn't like an air
fryer is a convent is a convection oven
and like it can make things a little bit
crispier on the outside because there's
air circulating because that's what a
convection oven is but like our oven has
a convection setting so
why would i want an air fryer um that's
some slick marketing though yeah i mean
so
so uh i'll just throw this out out there
we actually have both an instant pot and
an air fryer um
they they were both uh christmas
presents to my wife and she does use
them from time to time um
and so like i i'm so stubborn about
using them that like
we have both an instant pot and an air
fryer in the house i have never touched
them and i never will uh
you know if if i want to pressure cook
something i'll i'll just use a pressure
cooker and if i want to air fry
something like we have an oven with a
convection setting like why would i
break out another piece of equipment
that i gotta get from a cabinet plug in
some random little [ __ ] that i have to
clean afterwards like no no i'm just
gonna use the oven yeah how about you
my answer is basically just yes
like
so like i i couldn't think of a specific
thing and and then i started reflecting
on why that is
and it's because i've told every person
in my life
there's a standing kind of order
never get me anything
especially not like a a gadget or
technology so like there is no influx of
like gifts of like hey here's a new
gadget that i have to navigate and
decide if i like it so that wall is
completely closed off and then on the
other side i do not seek out any kind of
gadgets or anything like that because
they just don't interest me so i was
trying to think of
where i like a single answer and it's
just yes i just don't seek out new
technologies or gadgets and to to kind
of uh
give a little anecdote to support this
if i have something that needs to be
done
and i find something that almost kind of
gets the job done i stopped there so
like a new technology once i get it to
do what i want it to do i do not explore
or interrogate that any further i do not
try to optimize it i don't tinker with
it
it gets the job done i say fine good
let's not change anything so
i was
in grad school introduced to the concept
of an external monitor so like a second
monitor for your computer and you can
kind of drag something from your main
screen onto your second screen right
i had been using it
for four years
backwards
so the monitor was set up to the right
of my primary screen and to put
something on it i would drag something
off the left-hand side of my screen
uh
i had been doing that for four years
because it worked well enough and i
assumed this was just what everybody
puts up with yeah and then someone was
like
why don't you just change the settings
and put it on the other side yeah and i
was like i know it's it's actually not
possible and they're like it's extremely
possible it's what everybody does within
10 minutes of using this it's like a
like a super mario bros 3 screen wrap
level
uh sure yeah i'll take your word for it
but uh basically technology gadgets
i don't i mean you mentioned you were
telling me for two years to get a better
computer i was doing video editing on a
computer that had no business doing
anything in the realm of video editing
but i was like whatever it works i like
it it's for me
given the amount of time it took that
computer to render a video like
if if you were working for for minimum
wage
just the time you saved from rendering
videos would have paid for a new
computer over the course of a single
podcast season
yeah just in terms of like like dollar
value of time yeah but i i did find a
nice workaround where i would just do
all my stuff overnight but yeah i have
to like
very strategically arrange my day and be
like okay
yeah if i get this thing going at 9am it
should be ready when i wake up
it's like uh it's like old-school like
statistical computing
yeah like you mentioned how like if you
want like back in the day if you wanted
to run a multiple regression you just
turn your stuff over run errands for
about six hours come back see if the
results were there yeah that was
my advice to everyone is
do a bunch of uh statistics coursework
in your life go get all sorts of degrees
and crap
and just make sure you take stats with
the oldest possible stats professor
because their stories are great man
because like man i had a professor who
had retired like six years ago but he
just kept coming back to teach this
course
um
and so i mean he was you know he was
getting up there in age
and
he would
he resented us
because he was like you you kids do not
know how good you have it because like
right now if you want to do a linear mix
model with all the bells and whistles
uh
you just do it you hit run you probably
did it wrong and you get 11 error
messages right he's like dude if i
wanted to do a regression model with
three predictors i'd have to do it and
go cut my grass and go grocery shopping
and put some laundry in and like come
back six hours later and it'll be like
hey you forgot a comma try again
uh but yeah if you get a uh
a stats professor going about what it
was like in the old days
they have so many so many grievances and
so many funny stories
um
and then there was the days where before
personal computers were accessible you
had to like write all your commands on
individual cards and bring them to the
singular university computer and just
bring a stack of cards come back in
three days and then they'd be like yeah
one of your cards had a mistake it
didn't run and you're just like well all
right i'll try again next week
um but anyway let's uh we've got one
additional question here uh and this is
a good one to end with so
greg uh
well who's this question from uh penguin
riot one asks what are your favorite
podcasts other than iron culture and joe
rogan of course
sure so my
my top three favorites
and i think i've mentioned either one or
two of these on the podcast before
uh but but probably my favorite podcast
these days is called five to four
uh if if you're searching for it on
spotify or itunes or whatever it's just
five hyphen four
uh it's a us supreme court podcast that
is
far more entertaining than that little
uh
than that brief description would would
uh allude to
um
but yeah like it's
it's great uh you should check it out
it's it's so funny uh like one of the
hosts peter
his the the
connections his brain draws are are like
just
it's it's
it's [ __ ] that i would never come up
with that's so funny in just like a very
dark way
um
but
peter and rhiannon and the other hosts
they're they're also uh excellent
rhiannon has has one of the most
infectious laughs in podcasting i think
um
number two is probably knowledge fight
i've mentioned that on the podcast
before it's uh it's two comedians just
just covering the goings-on in alex
jones world uh and since uh since alex's
first defamation trial wrapped up
recently uh this is actually a podcast
on the rise right now it's been been
shooting up the charts um
the the guys from that podcast have
actually made some like traditional
media appearances they were on i i
believe the last week of brian stelter's
show on cnn wow which is very funny like
they
they go on like a big like national
media show and then like the next week
that show is cancelled
um but uh
but yeah no so they're they're great um
very entertaining show and then uh
number three for me is is probably a
podcast called q anon anonymous which
is very similar to knowledge fight it's
just like three dudes who uh
talk about what's what's going on in
like
the conspiracy world these days um it
started out as more of a knowledge
fight-esque thing like knowledge fight
covers alex jones q anon anonymous back
in the day mostly just followed kind of
like humanon proper uh but ever since q
stopped posting
uh consistently like he he popped back
up maybe like a month or two ago only
posted a few times yeah it didn't make
that many waves but now now they mostly
cover just kind of like
the broad conspiracy griftosphere and
it's it's also very very entertaining um
and you know so
get having given those answers i'm sure
some people will be asking why not
fitness podcasts there are no fitness
podcasts on your list i'll tell you why
i don't listen to fitness podcasts uh
fitness is my job
um
and i i do
i
work less than i used to but i still
work
entirely too much um
and most of the work i do is stuff that
i have to like focus on pretty hard
as i mentioned like words words are
challenging for me so i can't like i
know some people say like oh yeah i just
put on like podcasts is like background
noise when i work that's crazy to me
like i can't do that um so yeah i'm
listening to podcasts when i'm trying to
unplug wind down
um
and like yeah i don't want i don't want
anything going into my ears and into my
brain that is going to pull my mind back
to work um so yeah it's things just in
kind of completely different spheres
that i listen to
almost purely just for entertainment
value yeah how about you well i'm the
same way i don't do i
try not to consume too much fitness
content um just because we make fitness
content and i don't want to like
find myself in a situation where before
i read a study i've already heard
everybody else's interpretation of the
study i want to go into it with a blank
slate you know not have any kind of
preconceived ideas of what's going on in
the study so i i tried to
you know for that reason make sure that
i'm reviewing original research before i
hear others talking about it so i kind
of
uh opt out of a lot of the newer uh
fitness related content and like you
said uh in my leisure time because i
mean you know we do a lot of podcasting
and article writing and things like that
uh sometimes you just want to unwind and
do something different
so uh before i
before i list mine i want to acknowledge
on the front end i have a very high
tolerance
for hearing ideas that are based on
very unreliable studies
in behavioral economics and social
psychology
uh there are
many many journals that seem to
exclusively publish studies that are
interesting for books and podcasts
and will never ever be replicated yeah
they are simply not generalizably true
findings so i have a high tolerance for
hearing a podcast about those ideas
thinking about it digesting the ideas
but not necessarily taking it at face
value so
i'm not going to like unleash this list
of podcasts and say hey
always just whatever they say assume
that it's definitely very true and will
always be accurate so uh
with that out of the way uh i really
like to listen things that to things
that are about
uh human behavior or psychology
sometimes a little bit of politics mixed
in so i listen to uh the ezra klein
podcast
i listen to hidden brains sometimes
freakonomics sometimes uh
a podcast called unexplainable which is
more
more like stem
related topics based on the episodes
i've listened to
and then a lot of times i'll just put on
npr national public radio in the
background uh sometimes that's just for
the vibe npr it's like
the way that they approach the audio
medium is instantly calming to me
and yeah it just kind of sets a really
calm good vibe so like in the morning if
i'm working i just want to hear the the
very chill tones of npr in the
background as i'm like drinking coffee
yeah i
i don't i don't drive much like i used
to listen to npr in the car and i don't
drive nearly as much as i used to but i
i did particularly enjoy uh fresh air
with terry gross yeah because
jesus christ that woman has no
concept of social boundaries and
i love that in an interviewer where like
you know most most interviewers uh you
know kindergarten level interviewers if
they want to ask someone like a deep
potentially embarrassing very personal
question
they'll maybe
come up with a line of questioning that
that gradually leads into and builds up
to that
that uh kind of more intense stuff
you know to kind of give the the
interviewee some sort of indication of
like okay like this is where things are
leading this is where it's coming gonna
give you time to collect your thoughts
get in the right headspace to answer
this question terry gross uh
doesn't do that
like she'll she'll ask like one or two
questions that are basically
pleasantries and then just the very next
question cool now we're going to plumb
the depths of your soul yeah for a
national radio audience and i
i love that uh and i also really like uh
kai rizdel uh marketplace
um
i don't really even care that much about
a lot of the stuff they talk about
but his
his speaking cadence has such like um
yeah it just has like a such a smooth
cadence that there's almost like a
lyrical quality to it yeah um and it's
like it's vaguely hypnotic and i i enjoy
that yeah definitely
um outside of that i do like to listen
to sports radio from time to time it's
mindless um it's not important despite
all of the shouting that sometimes
happens on it but
um i like to stay uh
loosely connected to the sports world
and just kind of follow it as something
to
to pass the time you know um when
football season's in full swing i i do
become much more of a sports fan so so
that'll be happening here i'm even um
i'm
i'm kind of entertaining the idea
of
doing some sports gambling this year
without any money so i just want to i
just want to pick all the games and see
if i'm good at it if that makes sense
like i'm interested in the
the practice of predictive data analysis
and aggregation yeah uh
i i could never actually put money on it
because that that for me would be a
slippery slope that would end in
just a variety of misfortunes so
definitely not going to actually gamble
but i like to just stay on top of sports
and i feel like i feel like just from
listening to sports radio i'm like oh
i'd be so good at betting but i want to
actually see if that's true without
losing obscene amounts of money so i'm
still kicking around i think there are
some apps that allow you to do sports
gambling with fake money so you have no
actual skin in the game i think i want
to try that just to see if uh
if i can use statistics to like actually
know what i'm what to expect in a game
but we'll see i assume that everyone who
gets into gambling uh for sports
gambling is like oh i can predict this
stuff very well and just mathematically
that that can't be the case yeah uh but
anyway uh another thing i like to listen
to a lot is various buddhism podcasts so
if you're interested the ones i like are
buddhism guide audio dharma and then one
is called the way out is in
so
those i listen to when i am actually
going to pay attention
which is
probably only a tenth of my listening
habits like a lot of times i'll put on
something that i can drift in and out
but with those podcasts because
that the content is so nuanced it's like
if you miss a word you're like well i
gotta back it up again you know so you
gotta really be
uh on high alert as you're listening to
those yeah and those two things dovetail
really well uh sports betting and
buddhism like when i think like
there you can't
like up in tibet you know there's 24
hours in the day you're gonna sleep for
eight of them you're not gonna meditate
for 16 hours a day what are you going to
do you're going to open up your phone
get on draftkings
and
yeah i mean
that all makes sense well i mean like i
said i i have a rigid
a rigid rule in place
if if i do this with no skin in the game
there will never be a time where i allow
myself to actually put money down
because i just don't think
knowing myself that's not a good thing
yeah i'm never gonna do that but part of
me is just because i'm passively
interested in sports
and
actively interested in statistics i just
want to see how
how it would go yeah if that makes i'm
curious about
how well you could generalize
basic information about statistics and
probability
and just be like a passive sports fan i
want to see how well you can just mix
those together and be like oh i'm
actually an excellent better i have no
idea i assume it'll go very poorly
but um yeah it to me it seemed like it'd
be like a little fun hobby to kind of
stay on top of my statistical skill set
if that makes sense that makes sense um
all right so that does it for this
fireside chat um
hopefully um
hopefully this will be an audio and
video experience we'll see how that goes
like like we said earlier within the
next few weeks we'll be
putting out more podcast related content
who knows when
that will happen but but we're going to
be working toward our typical weekly
schedule and just working out all the
technology stuff as we go so as always
thank you so much for listening and we
will see you next time on the stronger
by science podcast
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you could sign up for the free
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you